daily from science mission transfer RNAs
that is tRNAs are known as adaptor
molecules in protein synthesis short
rnase are produced from mature trnas by
angiogenic mediated cleavage which is
promoted by sex hormones and their
receptors and are constitutively
expressed in breast and prostate cancers
suppressing expression of short rnase
reduce the rate of cell growth
suggesting that short Erinyes are
required for cell proliferation next in
addition to the Yamanaka factors
scientists have identified in nature
communications a soluble factor net rain
and its receptor ddc as modulators of
stem cell programming netrin-1
repression by transcription factors and
decrease in net rain induces apoptosis
mediated by receptor ddc resulting in
decreased stem cell reprogramming
efficiency netrin-1 also protects
embryonic stem cells from apoptosis
mediated by its receptor enc phi b
ensures that the treatment with
recombinant Metron one improves the
generation of mouse and human iPS cells
for more news visitors at www science
mission calm or science mission facebook
page thanks for watching